joining us now is bill rhoden a
columnist for espn andscape good morning
to you mr rhoden good to see you so we
just see the suspension has changed from
six now to eleven five million dollars
is that enough no no no and in fact at
first i was thinking uh you know i would
have done 15.
then after that how many games are in a
season they're 17. why would you just do
that well then and after i heard this
this nonsense his apology i would just
shut him down for the season because
clearly he does not get it he doesn't
get it uh the browns don't get it this
whole thing is about the highest value
in all this being about money but really
listening to to watson
i'm thinking this guy clearly does not
get it he said i'm standing on my
innocence said you you've got to be
totally in denial and they're talking
about therapy and i i think that he's
probably i could see him sitting in a
therapy session said i don't have a
problem you got the problem i think
about the women bill whose lives are
forever changed and if that was his idea
of apology he needs a lesson or two you
know there seems to be no contrition but
on the other hand he's saying i didn't
do anything wrong yeah and and and and
some people would you really believe
that i think he believes that i think
he's in total denial and then you hear
the owner one of the owners d haslam
talking about this will be a good
opportunity for talk about sex
trafficking this isn't about sex
trafficking this is about your player
the person you
you you gave a boat level of money to
despite stuff you knew was coming down
this has nothing to do with with sex
trafficking and putting the burden on
women and that this is a whole moral
morass so this isn't a great day for the
nfl at all so bill the atlanta falcons
wide receiving calvin ridley was
suspended for the entire 2022 season for
betting on games he admitted to gambling
on football games how do you square that
with what we're seeing for you john you
don't that's women yeah no you you don't
you know but again
when you're talking about a league whose
highest value is money they're saying
this guy
is
screwing with our money so we're going
to shut them down for a year so where
does that that leaves you no wiggle room
when you come into a thing like like
watson the only thing you could have
done is shut them down for the season
yeah but you said not a great day for
the nfl but listen roger goodell did say
clearly he wasn't happy with the sixth
game because they could have left it
alone he said no no no let's let's go
back and visit that and the arbiter had
said that the behavior was egregious and
predatory and predatory and goodell
agreed he did up things it's 5 million
not a lot of money for deshaun watson
well yeah i mean i think you made the
point is his contract 230 million yeah i
mean a lot of money you know i mean 5
million is a lot of money but five
million dollars
i'm not poo pooing five million dollars
but how do you put but i think what
we're talking about here is how do you
put a value on women's lives i mean this
this boils down to you believe women or
you don't i believe women yeah you know
a period so no so five million dollars
what what's the value here i'm just
saying that the thing that's bothering
me is that
desean does not think that he did
anything wrong and clearly he did he's
got an issue he's got he's got a problem
yeah and i think the nfl has has come a
long way
you know they have come a long way but
uh i just think there's a moral morass
in lake erie with the browns wow i think
when you have more than dozens of women
speaking up you need to pay attention
it'll be very interesting to see what
the fan reception is there week 15. bill
rhoden thank you very much appreciate it